cette semaine pour refonder le système
hospitalier en france c'est l'objectif
que s'est fixé le ségur de la santé
lancé ce lundi
quelques 300 représentants du secteur se
sont réunis par visioconférence au tour
du ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
et du premier ministre edouard philippe
rémunération temps de travail
coordination entre la médecine de ville
et l'hôpital
autant de questions auxquelles devront
répondre les deux ministres la
revalorisation des soignants sera
significative la façon dont l'économie
de l'hôpital fonctionne a démontré
toutes ses limites il faut trouver
d'autres méthodes
la t2a ne doit plus être la seule
boussole de l'hôpital français c'est
avec une promesse de changement dans le
quotidien du personnel hospitalier que
le premier ministre a choisi d'ouvrir ce
c'est dur de la santé un personnel
hospitalier fortement mobilisés et
présents aux alentours du ministère
concerné ces soignants attendent des
actes concrets face aux revendications
qu'il porte depuis des années pour
certains étant donné que tu es quand
même pas mal de temps déjà qu'on demande
et que ne serait-ce que là avec le
sous-effectif
on est tous plus tôt on attend de voir
on attend de voir
on continue d'appeler à la mobilisation
parce qu'on a bien conscience que on
n'aura que ce qu'on ira chercher et que
le rapport de force est notre outil pour
rentrer dans la négociation et ce
rapport de force on leur cherche à
travers les mardis de la colère les
jeudis de la colère et puis plus
largement sur l'ensemble du territoire
dans une mobilisation des hospitaliers
plus de 100000 dit qu'on était fermé
depuis 15 ans et ça c'est pas normal et
donc on l'a vu là justement sur la
gestion de la crise où il nous a manqué
des lits il a fallu rouvrir des services
qui étaient fermés mais en est avec une
grosse grosse vétusté est donc là il a
fallu rouvrir ça et faire dans l'urgence
on l'a fait il ya un souci c'est notre
job c'est ce que je dis on en dise vous
êtes des héros
maintenant on n'est pas des héros moi je
me considère pas comme un héros je suis
soudain on est payé pour faire un job on
a fait notre job m'a lancé les
conditions qu'on l'a fait qu il
qui sont complètement déplorable mais
c'est pour ça aussi on est là il faut
pas qu'ils nous auraient le gouvernement
promet une nouvelle organisation du
système de santé sur l'ensemble du
territoire
reste à savoir s'il sera en mesure de
répondre aux revendications cibler des
soignants en première ligne depuis le
début de la pandémie de kobe 19